alex cobb has had a nice
run
and his last two starts have been
terrific mark kubaz and he's been great
really the entire season at home last
two starts 13 innings 11 strikeouts this
one earned run alex cobb has been
throwing his good two-seam fastball
splinter has been great knuckle curve
solid two my go-to's for alex cobb to
continue this good stretch he's on
especially here at the big a it's
getting lots of ground ball action
crawford last night all for five
at the top of the order
the split and it's rolled the walls who
shovels to cobb and a nice 3-1 put out
so the batter is mitch hannigar he had a
three-hit night last night
here's the next pitch and this is skied
into pretty shallow
center field underweighting making the
grab on that one a routine play for juan
lagarus that'll be the second out and
kyle seeger will be the next batter
that one misses outside and seeger works
a walk and will bring up ty france one
two
chopper over the middle fletcher gobbles
it up flips it to first and the inning
ends on a 4-3 ground out so good first
inning for alex knob you say
kikuchi this has been a breakthrough
year for him in seattle an all-star
six and four and a three four eight era
yeah his fastball velocity
averages going up too he's 91.97 about
73 percent fastball usage here's his
first pitch on david fletcher hits it
sharply and by the third baseman seeger
that'll keep that hitting streak going
fletcher's gonna head for two here comes
the throw and he slides in with a lead
double a 26-game hitting streak for
david fletcher
fletch lives again
down the line double not only the base
hits it's been extra base hits he gets
that one by seeger never easy to get
anything by kyle seeger but fletch
swinging early here's ohtani who's hit a
home run against kikuchi this year you
say three years older than ohtani here's
the pitch out of the way swinging a
pop-up and this is going to be out there
and shallow left center field going out
jp crawford is there to make the easy
catch and that is a huge first out for
you say kikuchi number one he gets
ohtani out number two ohtani can't
advance the runner fletch over to third
base here's the stretch and the pitch on
the window wall swinging a drive deep
into center field going back on the ball
kelnick to the wanting track up against
the wall makes the catch tagging at the
second
and now going back to second base is
fletcher he took off for third stop had
to go back to second but jared kellnick
back to the wall was able to make the
catch and that'll bring up left fielder
phil gosling here's the two-strike pitch
again and that one's waved and missed
and that was the slider got him swinging
and the inning is over so the angels got
the lead off double by fletcher but
never got him past second base but
kellnick with a base hit and his fourth
at bannon last night's game and that
came in the top of the eighth inning
snapped an 0 for 42 slump here's the
pitch swinging a line shot into the gap
in right center field that's in there
for a base hit the turn by kelnick and
he's going to stay at first after the
wide turn up with the ball is taylor
ward gets to throw into second base so
jared kellnick with a one out single one
out single by ward two out single by
legarres mayfield really trying to find
his legs at the plate 3-1 pitch it's up
and fletcher to the plate with the bases
loaded mayfield the nine-hole hitter
hitting
133 walks to keep the inning alive and
now david fletcher will bat with runners
everywhere they're loaded with two outs
breaking ball fletcher drives it left
center field comic after it
david fletcher
again
another double he's had a pair of them
in the first two innings it's three
nothing angels mr clutch comes through
once again boy the right man in the
right spot with two outs and runners in
scoring position he gets the slider and
this one he's had the slider down in the
zone the entire inning this one is up in
the zone so here's ohtani here's the
stretch and the one-two pitch now
to ohtani here's a fast ball strike
three called right on the outside corner
at the knees
you say kikuchi striking out shohei
ohtani that will retire the side but the
angels get three
three-nothing angels bottom of the third
runner at second two outs ward lined one
in the gap in right center for a hit and
he drives that one down the left field
line it is fair in the corner
iglesias is not moving well but he's
around third
and now trots home
and the angels have stretched the lead
to four nothing and taylor ward has two
hits tonight including an rbi double
yeah he was uh he was smiling all the
way around he goes i'm all right i know
what's going on i know i'm gonna score
rallies i saw that ball down in the
corner worst case scenario it jumps into
the stands i'm scoring anyhow but two
good swing tonight for taylor ward
getting a chance to play against kikuchi
here's jack mayfield set to bet mayfield
left center he got it
back gone
jack mayfield
and it's five nothing first home run of
the season for mayfield i love the way
he hit that baseball and he'd way
dropped his bat he knew and that's a
long way out where he had to go out of
the yard with that's a 17th home run now
allowed by kikuchi he gets a cutter and
we talked about kikuchi he gives up the
long ball can make mistakes over the
heart of the plate and now itani here's
the stretch and the one-two pitch and a
swing and a miss and a breaking ball
down and away for strike three and
that's the second time that you say
has fanned shohei ohtani and that is
strikeout number five for you say
kikuchi here we go the bases are loaded
one away five nothing angels top of the
fifth cop from the stretch checks the
runners pitch to hannigar swinging a
line drive into right field going back
is ward to make the catch of the warning
track tagging at third heading home is
dylan moore hill scored tagging from
second going to third as shedlong jr
so the mariners finally get on the board
here in the top of the fifth they need
mitch haniger with a sacrifice fly deep
right field banks loaded
on the ground mayfield spinning getting
the out at second it's a little run
option play there to second base for
jack baker mayfield out when ice played
defensively at third base after the home
run two outs here's taylor ward and
here's the pitch lifted in the air it's
hit well into center field telnek is
going back still back it's out of here
kids center in front of the batter's eye
boy ward's having some kind of a night
homer double and single and the angels
add on it's now 7-1 lagaris still at
second two outs 3-2
got him
going off night for ohtani he has struck
out three times here's the o2 and
there's a swing and a miss down on
strikes goes raleigh and faces only
three in the sixth and
they don't get the ball out of the
infield against them in the inning and
you got fletcher's two for four with two
doubles and three runs banded in and
he's five for nine in the series
fletch to left
long his back
off the wall two runs will score lagara
scores mayfield behind him
fletcher ladies and gentlemen and now
you take a look at shohei ohtani stretch
and the 2-2 to otani in a swing and a
miss and a slider way down in it for
strike three and shohei ohtani has
struck out four times tonight but now
the mariners have runners on at first
and second with one out and that'll
bring up right fielder mitch haniger
smoked
down the left field line
a fair ball that's gone for a home run
mitch haniger unloads a three-run bomb
in the ninth inning one more out to go
he's ready and the o2 got him swinging
on a chain chip the ball game is over
beat seattle 9-4